about Zeus Dale's whereabouts since  Smith jr. lays it in  lowest if you knew the culprit this time  obliterated Griffin jr. running up the  court is ran over flake right here we  saw Blake  deter just running over him  the play is under review of the personal  foul was charged to Smith jr. the  officials will take a look at it they  could give a flagrant one on that kid  Blake was just standing there holding  his ground Smith jr. obliterated  see right they had ample time to go  around him wasn't interested in that  those repetition of both LeBron James  and frankly latina last year yeah Frank  went after LeBron so after the splendid  360 by submitted Union  commits this dubious foul right there  it is a flagrant one so it will be 2  shots and possession for the Pistons one  because he had time to Newton's  unmitigated illiteracy